hello I'm Michael hi I'm and I am in the
process of reviewing persona 5 royal I'm
currently 50 hours in and I just
finished the fourth palace and I'm in
the middle of August and that means
there's a lot more game ahead but I'm
gonna tell you about my experience so
far a lot of the first 50 hours is
persona 5 and it's gonna be very
familiar if you have already played the
game but that's also to say that it's
still an amazing RPG where style and
substance meet together and the message
that is trying to send are also
communicated through its striking
visuals and its amazing soundtrack
that's all there of course and there's a
lot more to dig into though as the game
goes on but so far I have seen a lot of
the new content and I'm going to talk
about the new character Kasumi because
she's kind of a big deal with royal in
terms of how this game is being pushed
and she's one of the exciting additions
but so far she's kind of been minimal in
terms of her impact on the story of
course you see her in the opening scene
during the casino heist I'm not gonna
spoil what Palace this is or where in
the Metaverse it is but she does have a
role in that intro which means that
she's going to be involved later on in
the game you get a little taste of what
she's like in the Metaverse but you also
have a confidante route with her now
it's only a five part confidant route so
it's a little bit shorter than every
other confidant and you get to spend
time with her in keachi Joji which is a
new area and you hang out with her she's
very bubbly she's a top-notch student
more importantly though she is a gymnast
and she has high expectations for the
school because she's going to surgeon
Academy and she has high expectations
for herself and that comes through in a
lot of the new scenes that she's been in
so far again nothing dramatic has
happened quite yet but we did get to see
a little bit of how she knows a kechi
which she thinks of the Phantom thieves
turns out she's kind of a cop so far I
hope she's not at the end another new
character who I think has made a bigger
impact in the front end of the story is
talking to a marquis and he comes in
after the first palace when you boot
kimochi des at a shooting Academy from
being a piece of [ __ ] but he comes in as
a school counselor and he is a perfect
thumb addict fit for persona 5 because
he is a counselor he
talks a lot about mental health and he
walks the characters through kind of
coming to terms with their trauma and
trying to overcome that and it's a very
comforting thing to have a character who
represents that and I'm kind of
surprised that the original game didn't
have that now that I think about it he's
kind of a klutz himself he's kind of a
goofball but he has a heart of gold and
his confidant round is very valuable
because when each rank you get extra SP
for Joker another change of confidants
is Gaurav kechi he's a major character
in the original game but now you have to
go out of your way to hang out with him
and rank up that confidant route I think
he's still a cop but so far his
confidant route it's just hanging out
with him and kiichi Joji which is kind
of nice but I'm hoping that it evolves
later on and gives a little bit more
backstory as to who he is especially if
you've already played the original game
for covenants as a whole there's an
extra element where the person you just
hung out with might call you right after
hanging out it's a little weird but you
do have some dialogue options in which
you can get two extra confidant points
so you can level them up faster now I've
mentioned key to GOG a few times which
is a new area in Tokyo you can hang out
in and there's a place called penguin
sniper which is a place for you to hang
out with your confidants or your party
members and you want to go there because
there is darts darts is an actual mini
game Hyuk is a style where you actually
use the motion controls to throw your
darts and you can call people up to do
that with them and what you get out of
it is ranking up your baton pass because
they're extra perks this time around for
a baton pass and we'll get to the combat
mechanics in a minute but at penguin
sniper you can also play pool pool isn't
an active minigame but there is
conversations that happen around
scenarios in which you decide to play
pool there's also a jazz club which is a
nice lovely place to hang out and
there's some sweet tunes that play in
the background that is also sung by Lynn
the singer for persona 5 soundtrack
which is a nice touch now that's a lot
of the new stuff on the social sim side
of persona 5 royal when it comes to the
meta verse and the dungeon crawling and
the palaces there has been some remixes
a lot of the new stuff in the palace is
kind of revolve around Joker's new
grappling hook this gets you to
different places within the palace so
there are extra rooms or some rooms have
been rearranged to be designed with the
grapple
in mind now some palaces have changed
more than others namely the 4th Palace
has a new sequence where you string a
lot of the grappling hook points to get
to the different areas in that room and
in all of these palaces our three will
seeds you want to find these because
they give us P boosts and when you find
all three of them you can convert them
into an accessory outside of the palace
once you finish it that recovery in sp
also helps you keep going in palaces so
you can have an easier time to do one
day dungeon runs and be a little bit
more efficient as you explore them it's
not just the design of the palaces that
have changed bosses have new phases as
well
the most memorable change has been in
the second palace where the boss spawned
different versions of himself that are
tuned to different elemental affinities
and with the game's combat system being
all about exploiting elemental
weaknesses the boss also exploits your
elemental weaknesses so there's a lot of
good back and forth while you're trying
to attack the main boss and kind of
makes you think about the combat a
little bit differently especially as a
boss battle that is already tough enough
as it is
now the SMT and persona combat system
has always been about exploiting
elemental weaknesses as I had mentioned
before but there are some added layers
at this time around in p5 are one of
them is the exploding shadows what are
they called distorted shadows and if you
kill them before they can act then they
cause area of effect damage on the rest
of the enemies which could get you out
of a bind
pretty quick they show up every now and
then but if you're not able to kill them
they do lay on a lot of damage so be
careful when they show up your personas
also have what are called traits which
act as perks when you fuse them in The
Velvet Room you can choose to have like
your magic tax do more damage or have a
higher chance of inflicting a status
effect on enemies or to protect yourself
from a status effect there's a whole
bunch of options out there so it's a
little twist on your personas and
customizing them in a way that you want
and as you've probably seen in the
trailers persona 5 royal has what are
called Showtime attacks which are
ridiculous they're absolutely adorable
most of the time and they lay on a lot
of damage
these unlock throughout the story and
they are partner attacks and there's
little scenes where like ayo you skate
you want to you want to team up I got
this new move and you see he's like oh
yeah [ __ ] I'm down and then so the next
time you go into the meta verse they'll
make mention of it and then you can pull
it off when one of the partners are in
the party so they don't both need to be
in the party for you to do that Showtime
attack you just hit the touchpad in that
clutch moment when either an enemy is
low on health or one of your teammates
is low on health and then you will see
this utterly ridiculous sequence of
events after the first time you see it
you can skip it though because they do
take a little bit a long time but I do
appreciate that they are there because
the combat revolves around exploiting
elements a weaknesses you can be casting
a lot of spells and p5 R gives you a lot
more opportunities to keep your SP
topped off as I had mentioned earlier
raising your confidant level with
marquise gives you extra SP for Joker
and finding real seeds and palaces will
give you a slight recovery boost and
also breaking up your baton pass so rank
3 means you get an SP boosts when you do
pass the baton to that character and
there's a meat shop and keeps you Joji
so get your meats that boy got some meat
on Sunday nights only get your meat get
your meat Sunday night Kichi GOG keep
your SP topped off you know I'm saying
another way to keep your SP replenished
is through a bunch of new items and you
can buy them from Joe say hey probably
wondering who he is he's a little boy
who roams around mementos when you visit
mementos you can now collect flowers and
you get stamps which you then cash into
him for different perks and items so if
you collect flowers it works as a
currency just for that day that you go
into mementos and he sells SP items very
useful ones too with the stamps that you
find in mementos you can actually change
the rate at which you either earn XP or
cash in mementos which is super helpful
and makes visiting mementos a little bit
more worth it
there's also a few new variables like I
remember going into the third level of
mementos and it was very dark and you
couldn't see anything so it's a little
bit of a new twist and also there's a
new memento song I'm not deep enough in
mementos quite yet to know if there's
any other songs but I'm excited to hear
something other than
[Music]
you know I'm saying mementos isn't the
only place that has new music new music
is littered throughout the game and I
don't have many hot takes but I'm gonna
say that the new ambush battle theme
takeover is better than last surprise
[Music]
sorry I will say that takeover is a lot
more in Phatak and it feels like there's
a little bit more momentum building up
going into battle when that theme plays
but also you know going into a battle
without ambushing the shadow isn't so
bad after all because you get to here
last surprise again so it's a knight's
touch so you don't have to ambush every
enemy we do get a little bit of a
consolation prize there so those are the
big changes that I've seen so far in my
50 hours of persona 5 royal there's a
lot more that I haven't covered a lot
more of my new details they kind of make
the overall experience a lot more
enjoyable and it makes the
moment-to-moment a little bit more
dynamic because of how many more systems
are layered on top of what was already
there with persona 5 of course there's a
lot more I haven't seen like the new
palace or what the new semester is gonna
add or how the end of the game may have
changed in p5 are those are the things
they're gonna determine whether or not I
feel persona 5 royal is the definitive
version of the game I have a lot more
work ahead of me and so much more of the
game to play but I am gonna take a page
out of persona 5s book and take my time
and when I do finish the game you can
expect my full final review here on
GameSpot
[Music]
you
[Music]